[Music]
you guys will find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift
i think we all have passions and you
don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them
you have to be looking for them and when
you find your passion it's a fantastic
gift for you because
it gives you direction it gives you
purpose you can have a job or you can
have a career or you can have a calling
and the best thing is to have a calling
and if you find your passion you'll have
that and all your work won't feel like
work to you
you never know exactly you know you
don't choose your passions your passions
choose you
how you how they are formed you're never
completely sure but i do think you get
imprinted somehow
early on certain things you just get
excited about them
and because you're excited you pay more
attention and they grow
and that's space is like that for me i
watched neil armstrong step under the
moon when
i was five the other thing i would
suggest
to any young person even before they
start their career
is to really think about their choices
because i find young people and i
i when i was young i had i made this
mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts you have things that
you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics
maybe you there are a lot of things that
you can be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life
it's your choices that construct your
life
not your gifts you can celebrate your
gifts be proud of them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be be
celebratory of them because you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them
you can only be proud of the things you
earn and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my
gifts i was always good at school school
was always easy for me
and i was always proud that i was a
great student i got a's in all my
classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life
of service and adventure which one of
those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of invent
it's really important to invent
anytime we have a problem we never
accept either or
thinking we try to figure out a solution
that gets both things and that often
requires invention but you can invent
your way out of any box
if you believe that you can if you want
to be an inventor of any kind
inventing a new new service offering for
customers or a new product or anything
being an inventor requires because the
world is so complicated
you have to be a domain expert i mean in
a way even if even if you're not the
beginning
you have to learn learn learn learn
learn enough
so that you become a domain expert but
the danger is once you become a domain
expert
you can be trapped by that knowledge and
so inventors
have this paradoxical ability to have
that
you know 10 000 hours of practice and be
a real domain
expert and have that beginner's mind
have that that look at it freshly even
though they know so
much about the domain and that's the key
to inventing you have to have both and i
think that is intentional
i think all of us have that inside of us
and we could all do it but you have to
be intentional about it
you have to say yeah i am going to
become an expert
and i'm going to keep my beginners mind
i did do a lot of soul searching i i
went to my boss at the time and i really
liked my job
and i told my boss i was going to go do
this thing start an internet bookstore
and um my wife and i had already told my
wife and she was like great let's go
and i i said to my bosses he's like this
is a good idea he says i think this is a
good idea but it would be an even better
idea
for somebody who didn't already have a
good job and
that sort of made some logical sense to
me and
he convinced me to think about it for a
couple days so i went away
i was really trying to get my head
around how to think about this
and i think for me the right way to make
that kind of
very personal decision because those
decisions are personal they're not like
data-driven business decisions they're
they are you know what does your heart
say
and for me it was i could the best way
to think about it was to project myself
forward to age 80
and say look when i'm 80 years old i
want to have minimized the number of
regrets that i have i don't want to be
80 years old in a quiet moment of
reflection
thinking back over my life and and
cataloging a bunch of major regrets
and i think that regrets our biggest
regrets in most cases you can murder
somebody
okay you'd regret that but in most cases
our biggest regrets turn out to be acts
of omission
it's paths not taken and they haunt us
we wonder what would have happened
i loved that person and i never told
them and then
they married somebody else i did you
know i didn't do this
and so that's the frame of mind that i
put myself in and i
and once i did that once i thought about
it that way it was immediately obvious
to me i knew
that when i'm 80 i would never regret
trying this thing that i was super
excited about
and failing if it failed fine i would be
very proud of the fact when i'm 80 that
i tried
and i also um knew that it would always
haunt me
if i didn't try and so that
would be a regret it would be a 100
percent chance of a regret
if i didn't try and basically a zero
percent chance of regret
if i tried and failed so i think that's
a useful metric for any important life
decision
the secret sauce of amazon where there
are several principles of amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful
by far is obsessive compulsive
focus on the customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often
to other ceos and
some other ceos and also founders and
entrepreneurs
and i can tell that even though they're
talking about customers
they're really focusing on competitors
and it is a huge advantage
to any company if you can stay focused
on your customer instead of your
competitors
if i collaborated with somebody here in
this audience and i said
look i want you to solve world hunger
and i want you to do it in five years
you would
properly reject the opportunity
you would say look it's not possible
it's not practical
but i said look i want you to solve
world hunger in 100 years
that's a job you'd take because it's a
much
more addressable problem you can first
create the conditions
you have time to create the conditions
where then you can solve the problem
and so that's that's a very important
way of thinking
and um and i find it's and it works
with everything i mean you have to back
up and find the right time horizon for
what you're trying to do but
you know at amazon we probably do most
of our things we expect
to get some results in sort of five six
seven
eight years but we find a lot of our
uh you know other companies that compete
against us in various ways
they're often trying to get things done
in you know two or three years and so we
can do things
that you know if you if everything has
to work in two to three years
then that limits what you can do if you
give yourself the
breathing room to say okay i'll i'm okay
if it takes seven years
all of a sudden you have way more
[Music]
opportunities
you